>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> John Cole: I'm John Cole.
I'm Director for the Center for the
Book and the Library of Congress,
the part of the library that
promotes books and readings
and literacy in libraries.
It was created by Daniel Boorstin
when he was librarian of Congress,
very much in the outreach
mode feeling that the Library
of Congress should
do more to reach out.
In those days to promote books and
reading and literacy was not part
of the vocabulary in
particular in the 1977, 78.
It is now and it's
another area for the Center
for the Book and our activities.
We've been involved from
the beginning with out,
outside activities such as
the National Book Festival
and we also have a network
of state Centers for the Book
to help promote books,
reading, literacy and libraries.
Most of that is really
working writers in the states.
And part of the spinoff from that
has been state book festivals
and regional book festivals,
especially since humanities
councils have become involved in 10
of the states now as our partners.
But here at the Library of
Congress, Books and Beyond,
some seats up front
please Carolyn and Tim.
The book festival has, the National
Book Festival has really inspired a
number of those regional book
festivals, because of our pavilion
of the states and with help from
IMLS and NEH and actually NEA
which also sponsors the
pavilion at the book festival.
We have partnerships with
other government organizations
and it's turned out to be a very
successful way for the Library
of Congress to reach out inwardly.
This Books and Beyond noon
time series, started in 1996
and it has featured books
that have been published based
on primarily the Library
of Congress' collections
but also collections
of other organizations,
plus a topic sent people of
special interest to the Library
of Congress and it's programs.
Abby is one of those who is
of special interest to us
because of her time at
the Library of Congress
and we're delighted
to have her back.
The program will last about an hour.
We will, it is being filmed for
the Library of Congress' website,
but it also will contain a
question and answer period
and we'll have the book signing
beginning in this room about 1:00.
Abby will repeat the
questions from the audience
and we would welcome them and want
you to know also there's a chance
that you might be part of our
webcast and thank you in advance
for your permission if that happens.
Abby Smith Rumsey is a writer
and a historian who focuses
on the creation, preservation,
and use of the cultural
record in all media.
Her specialized interest and I
had to go and take a few of them
out because there were a lot of
them, include digital preservation,
the changing roles of libraries
and archives in the electronic age
and the effect of new
information technologies
on perceptions of history and time.
Now a good chunk of Abby's
learning experience for better
and of course sometimes for not so
better but basically better has been
at the Library of Congress.
Way back in the early Billington
years, administration is
when the two of us first met.
Among other things she headed
several special projects
for Dr. Billington.
But curated two major exhibitions,
one was I remember well Treasures
of the Library of Congress,
the other called Unheard
Special Knowledge
of Russia called Living
Traditions of Russian Faith,
Books and Manuscripts
of Old Believers.
Abby being a Russian
specialist, she also contributed
to the library's historical display.
And I remember this very
well from Dr. Billington,
the historical display of
documents and so does Abby
of classified Soviet archives,
Revelations of the Russian,
from the Russian archives.
And for more than a decade
she worked with NDIP,
the library's digital
information infrastructure
and preservation program.
Abby's other contributions since
leaving the library include serving
on the National Science
Foundation's Blue Ribbon Taskforce
on sustainable digital
preservation and access
where she was the senior
writer and editor
of the taskforces second
year report.
She served on the ACLS
commission on cyber infrastructure
for the humanities and social
services and also as director
of programs of the council and
library and information resources.
Abby holds a B.A. from Radcliffe
College and an M.A. and PhD degrees
from Harvard University where she
specialized in early modern Russia
and intellectual history.
She was a Fulbright fellow
and taught and Harvard
and at Johns Hopkins Universities.
Would you help welcome me,
welcome Abby back to the Library
of Congress, Abby Smith Rumsey.
[ Applause ]
>> Abby Smith Rumsey: Thank you.
It is very nice to back, even though
I'm back with a different name
and considerably grayer hair
but I'm very happy to be back.
As you will see as I give this talk
and I'm not going summarize my book.
I'm just going to pull
out a few things
that I think are special interests
to this audience and other people
who love the Library of Congress.
But you'll see that I'm going
to talk about the technologies
of memory and why it is that we need
to pay attention to certain things
as technologies move
from print to digital.
In particular, I want
to focus on how changes
in technology effect the faiths
of collective and personal memory.
And the research that I did for
this book which included a lot
of science, led me the conclusion
that much of what we think
as our personal memory actually
is something that resides
in our collective memory.
We think that the songs of our
childhood our in fact ours,
our favorites but it's the culture
that provides this kind of richness
of experience and allows us
to understand the richness
of experience of past
generations as well.
And so I think that of
collective and personal as being
in some ways very closely tied.
Now the question that
I answer in this book
or at least I address shall we say
with some answers was
actually a consequence
of some rather frightening
wakeup call I got
when I was actually doing
the treasures of the Library
of Congress exhibition, when I
realized that all of the things
that we will be putting
out in the artifacts
that we would be putting
out, even high tech artifacts
like wire recorders and things
like that would actually
not even be there.
There would be no artifacts in 100
years that we could put on display
for another treasures of
the Library of Congress.
And so I started to ask
myself this question.
What happens when this
format, the default format
for our memories is
replaced by this format
which incidentally is not only
holding my you know, lots of books
and music but lots of
other things as well.
So in other words, what
happens when we go from,
I'm sorry this, there we go.
What happens when we go from this
vision of accumulation of knowledge
to this vision of accumulation
of knowledge.
So I make an argument in
the book that you know,
as we ask this question,
how can technology keep pace
with information explosion?
We need to actually rethink
and reimagine memory itself.
We too often think of it
as something that's fixed
on artifact when in fact it's not.
So I want to talk about and
I want to show you in fact
that data storage is not
memory, that forgetting is key
to remembering and that
most important of all,
memory's not about the past,
it is about the future.
It is in fact the raw material
from which we manufacture
what is to come.
So if you care about the
present and the future,
you better be good
stewards of the past.
Now I don't think I need to make
this argument too strenuously
to this audience, but since I
live in San Francisco I have
to really drill this
point home to people
who are busy inventing the
future with little knowledge
of how much the future is
actually just a reiteration
and a growth from the past.
You would expect that I
would find the importance
of the past really important
because after all I'm a historian.
But I really believe ardently that
the past is important to everybody,
especially now the past will
be written in digital code
which can't be read by
human beings with eyes.
Because you see, we humans
unlike all other species,
all of whom have memory like we do.
We have the unique ability
to accumulate knowledge
over generations and it's this
knowledge accumulated over thousands
of generations which is made us as
a species dominant over this planet.
And in fact through our
technologies we are discovering
that we are dangerously dominant.
So if we don't understand how
to be stewards of that past
and of the knowledge of
the technology gives us,
then in fact it's probably
the future is probably bleaker
than we can imagine.
So I think of the importance of
learning how to manage memory
in the digital age, not as a
technical issue fundamentally,
but as a moral issue which has to
engage every citizen on the planet
because we have a big problem.
The knowledge that resides in
these three buildings and beyond
at the Library of Congress is
really at risk of loss as you know.
Aha it worked.
So as you recognize this
room, it symbolizes everything
about what is actually an obsolete
system of disseminating information.
Because the publishing houses,
the movie and recording studios
that create and publish, book stores
and theaters that act as points
of distribution, libraries, archives
and museums as points of access
over multiple generations.
They have worked symbolic,
symbiotically
and somewhat mysteriously
but always stunningly well
to keep the past accessible
to the present.
But that world always operated in
an economy of information scarcity
and I know it sounds ridiculous
to say information scarcity
in the Library of Congress which
is overwhelmed by physical objects,
but compared to the internet there
really is information scarcity.
See the simple cost of
producing movies and books
and distributing them
and preserving them was
in a way a built in
filter of quality.
It had to be worthy of major
corporations investing a lot
of money and producing something
and they had a vested interest
in preserving these things.
It was one of the reasons why
they deposited copyright deposits
because they wanted that
information to be preserved.
So the upfront cost of production
always guaranteed some measure
of stewardship even if it
wasn't of the highest quality.
And then of course there
were libraries protected
by copyright legislation to take
on long-term stewardship
of these things.
So the rule of thumb in the analog
world has always been put your
knowledge into a durable physical
object, outsource your memory
to durable physical objects.
You save the object and you save the
knowledge and it's been that simple,
that complicated but
also that symbol.
But now in fact as you
know there's no way
that it works with this phone.
In a few years this phone
unless I update it constantly,
everything on it including my
personal contact information will
be inaccessible.
And furthermore the people
who wrote the code for this,
they can open up this
machine right now
and they won't be able to read it.
They wouldn't be able
to read anything
in here without more machines.
I want to point out and basically
I know this only because I worked
at the Library of Congress
and I got to know,
okay I understand the back button
is actually the forward button,
that won't happen again.
I want, I want to say for one of
the things, it's hard for people
to understand emotionally among
other things and technically
in the digital world is that
in fact digital machines stand
in the way of knowing everything.
It encodes all of the information
and we need machines to
read the information.
But I know from my friends in
MBRS that in fact it's been
that way for a long time.
In fact in audio it was
among the first formats
where it was machine inscribed and
you actually had to have a machine
to play it back, that was a very
important lesson for me I have
to say, so that in fact audio
recording was invented in 1860.
But the man who invented it actually
couldn't play back what he had
recorded and it wasn't
until just a few years ago
when Carl Haber was able to
retrieve some of that information
through very high technology
that he could hear what it was
that the Frenchman had recorded.
So in a way since the 1900s we've
always been dependent upon machines
for a lot of important information.
So I want to address in this talk,
first I'll go a little further
talking about the nature
of technology as such and how we are
to understand a relatively new
relationship of technology,
not entirely new but relatively new.
And then I want to pivot and talk
about memory since I wanted us
to reexamine what memory means so
I'll do a little bit of history
and a little bit of science and then
I want to pivot from there and talk
about some of the challenges that
we face and I would say actually you
in particular face as we
move into this new age.
So first I just want to say
a few words about technology.
Technologies of memory are very old.
They are probably the oldest
technologies besides tools
for cutting up animals that we know.
We've actually been using,
using durable objects
to remember things for
us for a long time.
What I'm showing here is an
image from 35, 40,000 years ago
from a cave near Chauvet, France,
a Paleolithic memo
to self or a prayer.
We really don't know what it means,
but we do know that it was created
by human beings because
after all they signed it.
And that's one of the things that's
so, to us in the present age missing
from moving from print
to digital is the
since that machines actually have
some human quality and I want
to talk about that,
because you'll see
that if this is a Paleolithic
selfie, the impulse to take selfies
and leave records of yourself
is just as vibrant today,
in fact it's more vibrant
in many ways.
But the important thing
about technology is
that technology is simply a tool,
it is an extension of human will.
It actually has no power of its
own other than what we grab to it.
So I'm not at all a
technological determinist.
I don't believe that technologies
will make us do anything
and the machines are
inherently threatening to us.
If machines are threatening
to us it's
because we are threatening
to ourselves.
So that's why I'm very
optimistic about trying
to master memory in the digital age.
Nothing is predetermined for us.
You know, the reason I believe
and this is my personal opinion,
the reason that we invented
memory technologies to begin with
and the moment in history
when we did was when I think
of when the Garden of Eden moment.
The moment whenever that was
in history when human beings
and clearly it was homosapiens,
not just, not just Neanderthals
because they didn't leave
records of their thoughts behind.
But when human beings finally or
realized that they were going to die
and not just so that other
members of their species would die,
but that they personally
would die and that
at some point children
would grow up knowing
that they too were destined to die.
And I think it's the reason that
we started to invent technologies
that essentially cheat death.
And I think that if we, I
think memory technologies are
in fact wonderful ways
to cheat death
and that drives a lot
of their application.
Technologies are also always
designed to solve a problem
or sometimes to meet a demand
or market demand for example.
And I'll show you some
examples of that.
But the think about clever human
beings and inventing tools is
that we solve one problem
and we create three
that we would never
have anticipated.
And we know when a
technology is truly successful
because then it gets
used for many things
that the inventors would
never have anticipated.
And we fall into this sort of
dizzying vertigo of lots of uses
of the technology no
one had anticipated
and this is what I call the havoc
phase of technology adoption.
And you know when technology
is really successful
when it reeks extraordinary havoc
in the first couple of generations.
So judging by that, I would say
that print was a hugely
successful technology
because it created huge
havoc after its invention
and certainly digital technology is
also dismayingly successful and it's
at a dismayingly widespread
havoc phase.
So the signs of havoc phase
and we can talk about this
if you want is always a
certain amount of infatuation
with the new technology, infatuation
with the technology
for its own sake.
A lot of fear about the technology,
a lot of [inaudible] inadvertent,
sorry information inflation.
So we actually start using
technology to start creating a lot
of information that then we
don't know what to do with,
that's the inflation phase.
And we always find over
time after a couple
of native generations have grown
up with whatever technology
that we actually are able to
tap in a new human potentials,
express something new about
the new human experience
through these new technologies
and that's why they're
so valuable to us.
So we have new writers.
We certainly have new audiences
and we also have changed
perceptions about human destiny.
Another thing that I learned
working at the Library
of Congress is how very powerful
the invention of moving image,
even silent film was in changing
the way that people were assimilated
into American culture
for example and the way
that people started to tell stories.
And the influence that, that movie
making narrative had subsequently
on the way we think,
the way we perceive time
and also the way we write.
So I want to talk a little bit
about some the things we
can expect from technology.
Technology always inspires
fear and also excitement
and some people praise a
new information technology
as disruptive and creative.
I would say that's my tribe
of Silcon Valley technologist
where I live among now.
And others condemn it as
disruptive and destructive.
And I want to talk about why both
those things are a little bit too
extreme and unrealistic.
But I want to take as this sort
of granddaddy example of this sort
of [inaudible] of technology.
Socrates, who famously warned
that the invention of writing,
something I think we all love
ourselves, that the invention
of writing would lead to
ignorance and ultimately
to the death of memory itself.
And here I want to quote
Socrates, "For this invention,
writing will produce forgetfulness
in the minds of those who learn
to use it, because they will
not practice their memory.
Their trust in writing
produced by external characters
which are no part of themselves
will discourage the use
of their own memory within them.
Users have invented an elixir
not of memory but of reminding.
And you offer your pupils
the appearance of wisdom,
but not true wisdom for they will
read many things without instruction
and will therefore seem to
know many things when they are
for the most part ignorant
and hard to get along
with since they are not
wise but appear wise."
I think we could say as
I've heard many parents say,
they don't know anything, they
know where to look things up.
So I think that's actually
a very common reaction.
But in my mind Socrates
got it wrong.
It was actually the societies that
adopted writing that progressed
and extended the reach of knowledge
and as we will see the reach
of knowledge is also the reach of
self-autonomy and self-liberation.
And after all let's not forget
if Plato had not been writing
down what Socrates said, we wouldn't
know that Socrates was ever alive
and Socrates was a great ironist.
I'm sure he knew that
he would be immortal
through the words of somebody else.
But I love this example of
Socrates because he points out first
and foremost, the moral hazard
of actually outsourcing our
memory to anything else.
Once it leaves our physical custody
then in fact it begins to do things
that we don't have any control over.
And I think that's one
of the underlying fears
that we're encountering
now in the digital age
when people put personal information
online for example, it's personal,
they're sharing it
personally and they don't
yet understand that's it's a
commercially owned platform
that is using that data
for its own purposes.
So you know, the thing
about technology is no one
can predict how it's going
to be naturalized by those
curious beings, humans.
And I want to take a case in point,
one very familiar to all of you
and that is the case of Johannes
Gutenberg, the goldsmith.
He invented movable type and he met
it to meet a very specific demand.
He didn't actually intend to invent
the Renaissance and the reformation
which is what historians
see in retrospect.
He actually wanted to
create, he didn't want
to create even a new
fangled technology.
He was trying to produce a
cheaper and faster version
of an old fangled thing, this
thing, the giant bible of mites.
And those of you have been
to the Jefferson building will know
what an amazing job he did knocking
off the old form.
He wanted to give people something
that looked like this only cheaper
and faster, so he was market demand.
And I know as a historian
of technology and ideas
that within 50 years the early
doctors of this technology,
you can say the early
print adopters,
the early print tech adopters
that ran with the technology
of most innovative and
effective ways come
in two tribes, then as they do now.
Initially, there's a
flourishing of pornography
and there was then the pornographic
images of the Pope for example,
really quite vivid and
were highly in demand.
And the second group are what
I would call euphemistically
ideological dissidence.
In the case of the
Renaissance there were people
who were protesting the
power of the Papacy.
And we call them because
they've become respectable,
we call them Protestants now
but in fact at the time they,
they were arguing for ideological
and I'd say theological utopias
that actually would be very
familiar to us from the headlines.
There wasn't anything that
Isis had invented in the way
of human enforcement and
persuasion that wasn't used
by Protestant sex at that time.
And the way they got a grip over
the human imagination was in fact
through the way of use
of printing technology.
Not that everybody read but all
you had to do was talk to somebody,
who had talked to somebody who had
read something that the Protestants,
these dissidents have published.
But you know, there was always
more there was always an upside,
not just a downside.
And my favorite upside story
of the printing revolution is this
man Michel de Montaigne who was born
in 1533 and you could say
that he was among the first
of the born print natives.
And he became an author,
he wrote his famous essays.
He became an author
because there was printing.
If there weren't printing he
would've written those essays
as manuscripts letters and
sent them to his family.
Instead he wrote his essays, he
published them, he published them
over many additions
over his lifetime.
And the whole genre of personal
essay that he invented was
so popular that it has never ever
gone out of print until this day.
That's something that all authors
in new genres can aspire to.
And if fact one of the things that
really struck me about Montaigne is
that he didn't just invent a new
genre, he invented a new appetite
and a new way of readers
thinking about themselves
and altering the way they
thought about themselves
and what they were capable of.
I want to move quickly, we're just
going to jump over a few centuries
and talk about our very
dear friend and benefactor,
sort of a patron saint of libraries
in this country, Thomas Jefferson.
Because by the time of the
enlightenment in the 18 Century,
knowledge itself, the thing that
was passed down through books
and other forms was redefined not as
something that was self-reflective
where we could learn about
ourselves and learn about God
but it was also a political agent,
it was a way of changing the world.
And I think because
we've grown up you know,
in the legacy of Thomas
Jefferson we failed
to understand how enormously
radical that was the time,
the idea that knowledge itself
was an agent of progress.
I mean it was a very
irreligious idea in many ways,
the idea that you wanted to change
the world, not to know the world.
But it was widespread and it has
taken over I think with the spread
of western thought and western
information technologies.
It's widely acknowledged now
that the world is something
that we can change
through information.
The other thing that we do
know about what happened
with enlightenment view of
knowledge is it imposed entirely new
responsibilities on the government
to provide access information
to its citizens.
There was no way that Jefferson
and his cohort believed
that we could be good citizens
without being well-informed
and so we have public libraries,
we have the freedom of the press
and other things that we know about.
The thing that fails to get lauded
as much as freedom of the press
and libraries as the responsibility
of the government is the
responsibility of citizens
to stay informed, that
was a part of the equation
that we don't talk
about very much today.
But it is in fact the vision behind
the people who invented the internet
and certainly the people
who put together Google.
I mean they wanted to
organize the world's knowledge
so that people could have access
to it and make it easy to find.
Things haven't turned out
exactly the way they planned
but that's just in
the nature of things.
I want to talk briefly about this
boom, this is a reading room one
of the earliest reading rooms
of 19th Century, in
Paris in [inaudible].
It was built in 1838 and you can see
that it embodies very revolutionary
ideas of accessed information.
Before this there was no student
reading room at the university,
they used to have to take
books back to their garrets.
But now they, he built
this large reading room
and because he used this incredibly
new technology called cast iron he
was able to elevate the ceiling
and put a lot of glass in
and he used a lot less
wood and it was another way
of protecting the books
from fire he thought.
So the thing about the technology is
that it always spurs other
innovations in ways of iterating
out the thoughts that
knowledge embodies.
I want to say that is was in the
19th Century and the radical growth
of knowledge with the understanding
that we can understand the world
and change the world
by learning more.
That we saw what I
think of as the root
of the today's information
inflation because I really believe
that it began in the 1800s,
it did not begin just a couple
of decades ago, that
was a difference
in scale I think and in format.
Because by the time, 1838,
1848, 1850 when we were starting
to build libraries on
the scale that we saw.
This ordering of knowledge, this
is Thomas Jefferson's catalog
of course, organizing knowledge
into memory, reason and imagination.
This was already obsolete.
There was no way you could organize
all the world's knowledge this was
according to these
faculties of the mind.
We started to develop, we started
to develop a demand for what turned
out to be the LC classification
system.
When you actually started to
classify information according
to what it described in the world,
also a completely radical idea
that would have never occurred
to anybody in the 18th Century.
So I just want to say before
passing on and pivoting to memory
that in sum, the real benefits
of memory technology, innovation
and memory technologies become clear
only when infrastructures begin
to catch up with the innovations in
order to order it to provide access
to it and to provide long-term
stewardship and enter to what is
in effect the post havoc phase.
I don't know how long we
will be in the havoc phase.
I think the post havoc phase will
occur certainly after I'm gone
and probably when my granddaughter
who is a digital native,
when she reaches my august
age and lives well beyond it,
people born now will live
well beyond their 60s, 70s,
80s, well into their 100s.
And they will actually be in
a position that most of us are
and when we look back
retrospectively and try
to make sense out of our
lives and that's when we begin
to understand the value of not just
keeping everything, but in ordering
in such a way that it begins to tell
us a narrative and it makes sense.
So in fact it does begin to map
what we know and experienced
in the world does begin to map
to something within our brain,
within our mind, within our spirit.
So I want to pivot to
memory now and again,
I have to confess the whole idea
of investigating memory is a way
of the science of memory occurred
when I was here at the Library
of Congress and we hosted
the decade of the brain.
It's funny how so many
of these insights I had
into memory really were born here.
So the purpose of memory which is
given to all creatures from amoebas,
to zebras is to supplement the
pre-programmed thing we're all born
with, DNA.
Everybody's born with DNA it
teaches us how to be an amoeba,
a zebra or a human being.
But every one of us
that's born actually needs
to learn our environment and so
we're given this capacity by nature
to remember the environment
in which we live.
We learn things and we
store that learning.
And when that learning, that
memory is no longer applicable
for the world that we live
in, we lose that memory.
Memory is highly dynamic and it's
intended to be highly dynamic.
So just remember that forgetting
is very important in memory
because there's a limit to
what every creature can know.
The brain also has a capacity to
sort out what's new, I mean in order
to figure out what it needs to
remember, it memorizes the world.
And in creatures that
are as complicated
as us it takes many years for us
to learn the world that's why
we spend the first two decades
of our lives learning from our
family and from the schools.
And then by adulthood we start to
actually counter things that reify,
reinforce what we've learned
and begin to act in the world
and change what we
know about the world.
And we, the brain mysteriously
can pick out what is,
we still don't have any
idea how it does this.
But it actually takes in a lot
of information every day
in short-term memory.
At night when we're asleep,
incidentally sleep is very important
for memory formation in ways that we
do not understand it actually starts
to sift out short-term memory
that it doesn't think
has any long-term value
and then consolidate the other
memory into long-term memory.
So we know from biology and
we are biological creatures
and our cultural habits are
extensions of our biology.
We know that information has
long-term value to the extent
that it has potential for reuse.
Now I don't have to tell
librarians that the whole point
of preserving is in order to
provide use in the future,
but we don't actually
in the digital age
yet understand how data
will be useful in the future
and I'll talk about that in a bit.
But first this brief example which
I talk about in the book which seems
to come as a great
surprise too many people
that don't understand
libraries and long-term memory.
The first is that bad things happen
when we don't say it
long-term memories.
And I give an example of a write
Iris Murdoch, this is Iris Murdoch
who was a prolific writer
and philosopher and later
in life succumbed to Alzheimer's.
And I think this picture was taken
when she first began to succumb
to Alzheimer's before
she was diagnosed.
Her husband John Bayley, a great
writer, wrote a very moving memoir
about what it was like to
lose Iris to this disease.
When she lost her personality
it wasn't just her memory,
she lost her perky
personality, her sense of humor
and most important I
think her imagination.
Because she had no memories
and she lost any understanding
of how the world worked, she
could not imagine anything.
You can see this among
Alzheimer's patients.
They get up in the morning and they
don't know what they are supposed
to do.
It isn't just that they don't know
where they are and that also happens
with deterioration of the
hippocampus and the disease,
but they actually have no
ability to imagine their future
because imagination is nothing
but memory in the future tense.
Memory is not about the
past, it is about the future
and the only reason we have a future
as humans is because we have enough
of the past to be able to
project into the future,
long-term into the future and
to do conjectural thinking
and solving problems.
So I want to talk about
the second disorder
which I think will bring
home to many people
who worry about digital memory.
And that is the fact that good
memory is not data storage,
it requires forgetting.
So we don't want to forget
everything and we certainly want
to keep long-term memories,
the equivalent
of what cultural memories
held in the Library
of Congress and elsewhere.
But we also can't store everything
and think okay job
done, that's memory.
In the book I talk about
the patient of this man,
this man is [inaudible] he's a,
he was a Soviet aeroscientist
and psychologist who had a patient
who couldn't forget anything.
And he had more than
a photographic memory.
He had actually a kind of disorder
of the brain whereby he couldn't
consolidate any short-term memory
into a long-term memory.
So he memories information
stuck to his head
like I don't know,
flies to fly paper.
But if you asked him to tell
you a story he couldn't.
He couldn't understand how
to put a narrative together,
he didn't understand cause and
effect and he said at the end
of his life that he actually was
sort of waiting for life to begin,
because he had never really
felt that it had quite begun,
he didn't know what to expect.
He couldn't hold down a job because
he kept waiting for something
to happen even though he
had this great memory.
He really couldn't move beyond that.
And his doctor said that in
reality his life took place
in dreams not in reality.
He had a family, a fine wife
and his son who was a success,
but this too he perceived
through a haze.
Indeed one would be hard put to
say which was more real for him,
the world of imagination in which
you live or the world of reality
which he was but a temporary guest.
So we, one of the tasks I
think so important for us
in this age is actually
to figure out how to sift
through important things, so
that we don't end up going
into our memory palace
and finding this.
And I know this is an extremely
cheap shot, forgive me John.
This is definitely one of my most
favorite photographs of any place
on the planet, let alone
the Library of Congress
and it is actually a sign
of librarians getting
their house in order.
But I do use this as an illustration
of the kind of sort of memory palace
that [inaudible] would have
encountered in his mind
because nothing sorted,
everything was just in piles.
This is actually, this is and
understand this is not a picture
of [inaudible] but this is an artist
wondering what [inaudible] must've
felt like when he was trying to
put things together in his head.
And as you know this was actually
the library of Congress moving in,
in 19, 1997, in 1897 into its
new home, the Jefferson Building.
And of the most treasured facts
is that of course they outgrew
that building pretty quickly so we
know that library's a core vacuum
and so do servers,
so does the internet
and so does YouTube and Instagram.
So given that this is the
challenge that I've laid out,
what do memory institutions
supposed to do now.
And here I'm not going to claim that
I have any more knowledge than you,
but I do want to let you know
what I have been telling people
who don't understand what the tasks
at hand are and I'll go very briefly
through this because you
already know the answers to this.
First I talk to people about
how we need to rescue the past
and we can do that a lot
through technologies.
I really believe that in 20
years if our analog assets,
if our analog information is not
accessible and findable online,
even if it's just a pointer to
something then nobody will know
that it exists because people
will by default go to the web,
go to what the new
version of the web is.
And I show here a picture of Carl
Haber, somebody that the Library
of Congress doesn't actually
supported a great deal in his work.
He's a nuclear experimental
physicist,
developed an imaging technology
for the large Hadron Collider.
He's a kind of a neighbor
of mine in Berkeley,
he works at the Lawrence Berkeley
Laboratory and CERN in Switzerland.
And he said that he could,
figured out his imaging technology
which goes down to you know, the
kind that can image it [inaudible]
when they actually catch one,
was also good for imaging
deteriorated audio files, I'm sorry,
audio formats turning them
into three, two and 3D images.
So you could actually take a picture
of a broken platter and turn it
into a digital file
and play it back.
So we can actually use
machines not just to digitize
but to capture information
which we can't play back.
And as I think so many of you
know when we convert things
like ships logs that have a lot
of information about centuries
of sea conditions over time, there
are very hard to make sense of.
As a scientist for climate
information you have
to read each page but now
that they've been digitized
by the Wellcome Trust
and Naval Museum
in London they are actually
a source of huge information,
pattern recognition and
great retrospective data
for climate scientists.
So I think again, I tell people that
there is more information lurking
in old formats than
we can possibly guess
because we don't what
technologies we'll be able
to discover from what exists.
The other thing that I
preach I think to be fair is
to save the present and this is
an example of saving the present.
You may know Brewster Kahle,
this is a picture of him
in the early days in
his internet archive.
This is one of the few archives
dedicated to capturing the web
and also making it freely available
to people to actually upload
to their own images and
their own files online.
So it's more than just web archiving
that he does on behalf
of the public.
He also allows individuals
to put their files up.
Many of you will wonder
what can people do
in the interim while places like
the Library of Congress are getting
up to speed when the infrastructure
is being built out to start
to steward the digital
creation that's going on now.
And I think this is
a critical time now
that individuals have a
huge difference to play.
They need to develop their
own territorial profile,
save their own files and
develop a kind of digital persona
and take responsibility for ensuring
that all of the data they want saved
which they posted to Facebook or
which is on Gmail or something,
some platform that's not out
their own, that they are able
to preserve it themselves and
if they wish to, to share it.
And if there be more
places like the internet,
the archive can be
deposited and hopefully places
where it can be deposited without
being shown for longs periods
of time if they wish
to have an embargo.
I just want to, before I close
say that the final risk I think
and I want to get back to the moral
issue is that we are in a period
when we believe that progress
is never-ending and that
in fact the knowledge that
we have now will sometime,
at some point supersede
the knowledge that we,
the knowledge that we create
supersedes past knowledge.
And all I can say is that nothing
can be further from the truth.
This is a, from an atlas in the
1850s in which the scientists
who became mad about
cataloging all extinct species
because they finally understood
there were extinct species,
put together catalogs full
of extinct species including,
and you can see in the corner
above the volcano, the dodo.
And I would say my friends in
the Library of Congress finally,
the most important
lesson I learned here
which I hope I address
adequately for your sake
in my book is the importance
of never ever looking
at knowledge created by human
beings since society as extinct
and superseded, that
cultures can come and go
but no human knowledge is ever, is
ever extinct and it's never worthy
of being blown away or flushed
away or simply overwritten.
It's very important in the
digital world that we understand
that the faster a culture is ahead,
the more we actually need the past,
the ancient past in some cases to
help us struggle with the future
and I just give you
an example of that
without recovering the classical
learning that was mostly lost
from the Library of Alexandria
that we would never would
have had the Renaissance,
that we would never had
had the Reformation,
we would have the modern
era and it was simply
because in fact the Library of
Alexandria, although it was allowed
to dissipate never ever
actually totally disappeared.
And so I think with that note I'll
say in mind there's nothing more,
there are no institutions
more important in this age
than not just libraries, but
specifically the Library of Congress
which I think needs to
reexamine and redesign its role
in the digital world but I think
will be far more significant
as everybody its struggle dealing
with digital memory personal
and we'll look here first for some
guidance and how to think about it,
not just in policy issues
but also personally.
So I want to thank
you all very much.
And I know I've talked
for quite a while
and I'm eager to hear
your questions.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
Yes here's a question
in the back now, mm-hm.
>> Do you want to say anything about
a role that copyright will play
in assisting the preservation
from cultural heritage?
>> Abby Smith Rumsey: The question
is what role could copyright play
in assisting cultural heritage
preservation right, digital.
Well it could actually if we had
some robust digitally friendly
copyright laws.
Although I'll have to say and you
know, I mean I was involved in some
of this work with ended
as many of you may know
and it did look seriously
at making recommendations,
did make recommendations
for the copyright office
to updating the copyright
law for the digital age
and I've actually come to the
cautious conclusion and I'm sorry
to say this in this
company in some ways.
But I actually wonder if copyright
is any longer the most effective way
to ensuring that things get
deposited to a central location
like the Library of
Congress and then become,
the Library of Congress
become the sole institution
which I can actually take
responsibility for preserving this.
At least in the UK there
is a distributed copyright
deposited system.
But I think because the copyright
has been so, lagging so far behind
in the digital age, the
people simply develop new ways
to get around it.
It wasn't working and so
people now just, well you know,
publishers actually
don't sell anything
and they don't allow copyright
in some ways to be invoked
because they license materials and
that seems to be working very well
as a business model for
many, for many publishers.
So I actually, I have to admit
that I don't know the
answer to that question.
I really don't know how
copyright can serve as direct,
a salvation role shall we
say in cultural preservation,
because we will not be
saving physical objects,
you know we won't be able to
acquire an object and keep it safe
for a long period of time and
then look at it in 50 years.
We have to also have the code and a
lot of things which are not covered
by copyright law in terms
of proprietary issues
but there's always hope.
Yes.
>> I'm wondering what groups are
out there today that are trying
to perhaps interact with Library
of Congress or government agencies
to preserve the digital
information [inaudible]?
>> Abby Smith Rumsey: The question
was what are the groups out there
that are working with the Library
of Congress and government agencies
on extending the life of
digital information shall we say.
Well I certainly know that, that
well I think it is reasonable
to assume that there are two sectors
that have solved a large number
of problems that we in the
cultural area aspire to solve
and those would be first
the commercial sector
and we will be talking about the
technology bohemists like Amazon
and Apple and Google whose
[inaudible] is the use
of digital data.
So they're very interested in
reusing data and reuse of data,
securing reuse of data
is the first step
in long-term preservation
in the digital world.
The other group which I don't know
anything about, if anybody want
to enlighten me is of course
our national security agencies,
they also and the DOD.
And you said which government
agencies have been working
with the Library of Congress
and I'd say well I don't know
which ones have been working
with the Library of Congress.
But there are, I do think
that and I can't say this
about National Security, but I
can say in my limited observations
of the technology sector is that if
consumers demand certain services
from Facebook and Google and Apple,
they will be met more than half way.
When consumers first
realized the privacy settings
in Facebook actually
weren't very private at all,
they demanded that they be
modified and Facebook modified them.
I think you know, consumers
will always be one step behind,
but I just, I do think that
there are, there's reason to hope
that Amazon, Apple and Google,
well probably not Google but Amazon
and Apple are working
very strenuously
on developing consumer based
digital preservation solutions
so there would be just
like they have you know,
solutions for buying
music and buying books.
You'll be able to do more than
just rent space on Amazon cloud.
You will be able actually
to have very tailor made
digital archiving programs.
But I don't know very much
more than people are working
on it at the consumer level.
Yes Carl.
>> Well I've mentioned in
the same breath in addition
to the ones you've
ticked off, science
and the science related domains that
there's a tremendous amount going
on with weather data,
astronomical data and so
on that it's seemingly being
managed and curated and preserved.
>> Abby Smith Rumsey: Right, Carl
was just pointing out the fact
that a lot of the weather data
and scientific data is seemingly
being managed and preserved.
And if fact we did when I was on
a NSF task force there was a fair,
it was a while ago but there
were, it's pretty clear
that they understand it's an
urgent issue and there are a lot
of problems that they haven't
solved, but they are endeavoring
to get money from the government
to solve them [inaudible] Carl.
Yes.
>> Again I, when I ask questions
I always have to say I'm not
from the United States, I'm
from the Caribbean so I'm
from a different part of
the world which you know.
And one of the big
problems that break away
from us obviously [inaudible]
is that in Africa,
in the Caribbean it's
a little bit different,
the Caribbean is second rate,
second you know but since we're
in America lots of places,
Latin American and Asia,
a lots this digitalization
at the same time tremendous
societal changes taking place
in oral based cultures.
I mean you can decide
the fact that you know,
we need to remember the past to
be able to navigate the future.
If this oral based culture is
[inaudible] I mean I see it even
in my [inaudible], you go to ask
Google about a name of a person
and click and no one
remembers the person, the,
the person just disappeared in
this kind of memory hole right.
So that's the first
thing, the second thing
if it's a big problem then what kind
of memory is being
remembered here right.
Mostly memory of so
called [inaudible] but all
of its [inaudible] right is
being, not fully remembered
but mostly remembered
right which [inaudible]
and the third I think most important
thing we didn't talk about here
but I think others are touching
on is how do we keep memory alive
and keep memory vibrant even in a
digital sense when memory is based
on the essence of a whole
set of [inaudible] breaking
down at a horrific speed
and the realization
and the optimization of
the individual right.
How does this play in role
in this entire creation
because I think it
complicates [inaudible]?
>> Abby Smith Rumsey:
Yeah you're right.
And let me just summarize
if I might,
certainly two points I can address,
one I'm not sure I can address.
The first is about the loss of
oral culture and what happens
to that in the digital age.
And I might say oral culture has
been lost in the print age too.
And the second is how do we actually
think about a collective memory,
is that what you're saying because
of the atomization of society
as such and it's very interesting to
me, because I actually gave a talk
at Google not too recent,
not too yeah fairly recently
and the audience was much younger
and they had an extremely
different set of experiences than
and perspective than this audience.
And if fact they were,
they were very much saying
but you know the great
thing about the internet is
like I read this thing
about oral culture,
it's like we're reinstituting
an oral culture
where people tell each
other stories all the time.
And we share things through
Instagram and Facebook.
And so they actually wanted me
to talk about as an intellectual
about oral culture and the
shifts about the human psyche
and human community relations
when oral culture went to print
and so now they're saying but what
if print's actually
going something oral.
Because it is, the digital
is a femoral the way oral is
and it's filtered the
way that oral is.
So I've been thinking
a lot about that
and I think there's a lot too it.
And the second thing
is I would argue
that whenever the world falls apart,
the world also comes together.
I mean I think the world as
we now know it is fracturing,
but that doesn't mean that
it's going to remain fractured,
that it's simply realigning
itself in the way
that libraries are redefining
themselves that in fact people,
the urge for community actually
has been accelerated in the ability
to build communities, has
been rapidly accelerated
through these communication
technologies.
I mean I call them memory
technologies because I'm interested
in you know, recorded history.
But in fact for most people these
things are like telephone calls.
I mean they're actually
communication technologies
and through those they actually
are building very wide communities.
I think that the social
media are so successful,
because they enable
people to build communities
and to tailor communities and
to find like-minded people even
if they're physically distant.
So I would actually argue
that in fact although one set
of community organizations,
in my mind actually very much
around church are breaking down
in certain communities certainly
in the west, he said he's from St.
Martin so it might be different
in his, in the Caribbean.
But then in fact people
have a hunger for community
and they're just one reason why
young people love this technology
so much is because they get to
create their own communities
and they glom on to it and they
don't care whether we approve
of it or not.
Well that's a part of
being young I suppose.
So I'm actually quite optimistic
about that and I look forward
to actually following the emergence
or the redefinition of orality
as a kind of cultural
exchange through this medium.
Are there other question, comments?
Okay I want to thank
you all very much.
And I want to say a word before we
break about how really happy I am
to be able to thank John Cole
for everything that he's done.
In some ways John is responsible
for at least the good parts
in this book, because if it weren't
for John I would never actually
have been hired and allowed to stay
on the Library of Congress and
John was the one who kept me
at the Library stubbornly you
know, contract after contract
until I landed a position here.
And so I want to thank you
personally and deeply John
for all that you've done for me.
Thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well thank you Abby,
that was not the part of the deal.
But I do have a story about the
picture that Abby showed in the 19,
the 1897 building of
everything on the floor.
That picture first appeared
in my first chronology
which was published in 1978.
And the only reason it
was allowed to appear was,
I didn't tell the publishing officer
that the communications officers
said never use that picture
and never allow it to be published
until suddenly there it is.
It's good to see that again.
So communication does
[inaudible] in every way.
Well Abby that was a wonderful talk
and I really, I want you to know
that Abby's book is
getting wonderful reviews.
And we're very pleased to
be, that she told us about it
and that she is here today,
so we're previewing this
with the Library of Congress staff.
You can buy a copy if there are a
few left and it looks like there are
at the Library of Congress
discount and get her to sign it
and let me offer our congratulations
to Abby on the learning the lesson
so well here and being able to
articulate them on our behalf just
in the way we liked to be
put forward into the world
and for her wonderful words about
the Library of Congress itself.
Let's give Abby Smith Rumsey
another round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.